bienvenidos a la segunda parte de la
presentación de trigonometría básica los
últimos diez minutos tuve problemas para
obtener más ejemplos así es que haré un
par más con ustedes empecemos
voy a dibujar un triángulo rectángulo y
voy a hacer los lados al azar
digamos que este es el triángulo
stella 16 y este 55 pongámosle 5
y luego si este es un triángulo
rectángulo esta es la raíz cuadrada 36
más 25 es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 61
entonces
entonces este lado de la raíz cuadrada
de 61 entonces comencemos con algunos
problemas
si les pregunto llamemos a este ángulo
teta
y quiero saber cuál es la tangente de
theta
cuál es la tangente de este ángulo de
acá
cuál es la tangente de este ángulo
probablemente hayan olvidado la
definición de tangente entonces la voy a
repetir lo voy a escribir en esta
esquina
solo acá
tohá
así se refrescará su mente de que todas
es la nemotécnica de tangente
entonces la tangente es igual al opuesto
entonces la tangente de theta es igual
al lado opuesto este lado 5
sobre 6
exactamente del 3 5 sobre 6
veamos todos los trucos de las funciones
los trucos básicos de las funciones
entonces cuál es el seno de theta
usaremos entonces la mnemotécnicas o el
opuesto sobre la hipotenusa
el lado opuesto nuevamente 5
y que deporten usa la raíz cuadrada de
y a muchas personas no les gustan los
denominadores irracionales entonces
vamos a racionalizar el denominador
entonces esto es igual a 5
es igual a 5 sobre la raíz cuadrada de
61 por la raíz cuadrada 61
esto es igual
raíz cuadrada de 61 sobre este cuadrado
el 61 entonces
el 61 entonces el seno de delta de teta
es 5 raíz cuadrada 61 sobre 61 y luego
finalmente voy a borrar acá
y probablemente aún se preguntan si
estoy tratando de obtener este coseno
completo cuál es su uso y les puedo
decir ahora la forma de obtenerlo y
usarlo
en la siguiente presentación les voy a
mostrar que la trigonometría es una de
las materias más útiles en las
matemáticas pueden calcular muchas cosas
la distancia de los planetas la altura
de los edificios pueden calcular muchas
cosas con la trigonometría
más adelante estudiaremos los senos que
en realidad describe casi todo
ok bueno volviendo al problema ahora
veremos el coseno
volveremos con la mnemotecnia
jose no de teta entonces este es el
ángulo que define al coseno que es igual
a 6
es igual a este 6
sobre
la hipotenusa que es la raíz cuadrada de
61 entonces tenemos 6 raíz cuadrada 61
sobre 61
son un poco desordenadas estas cifras
pero creo que ahora tienen el dominio
para hacer el cálculo
si se ven los lados del triángulo pueden
calcular el seno el coseno o la tangente
de cualquier ángulo dado en este
triángulo rectángulo obviamente pueden
calcular este ángulo
pueden obtener una cifra interesante
voy a terminar esta presentación en la
siguiente presentación les voy a mostrar
cómo calcular si tenemos el seno el
coseno o la tangente de un ángulo y
sabemos uno de los lados entonces
podemos calcular los otros lados
va a ser muy interesante nos veremos en
la siguiente presentación